do we need like an ai that don't i don't
want an ai
government but i would like an ai
advisor for our government no but the
thing is an
ai advisor would be i think
completely utilitarian we would not as
human beings be comfortable with what
they recommend or what it recommends
yeah they'd be like hello ian you must
die today because
it will save three children i disagree
uh maybe we could have like 90 uh
artificial intelligence advisors
this is one of the biggest challenges
with self-driving cars they someone has
to program in the car
if you're driving in your car and an old
lady walks out in front of you
the car has to choose do i crash the car
killing the driver
or hit the old lady lady someone's got
to program that
yeah and those those are deep
philosophical questions that i think
even as humans we don't understand
and we need to have debates about which
we aren't really doing right now we're
kind of just like
kicking the can down the road but i
don't expect a machine to do if you were
driving and the car was like
ian will you die to save her as you're
like you're like
i don't have time to think about could
you could you imagine like so you
mentioned that ai would be utilitarian
but i think it's the only thing it
possibly could be how could there be an
ai that was deontological in that it
would say
catholic ai i don't know no but imagine
it's like
it has to save everybody but it's not
possible
yeah so it's like imagine you're in the
scenario where the car is driving
and the old lady let's let's say
something happens through
it's a no fault scenario no one is at
fault just
uh something happens avalanche no no
it's
there's got to be two people that one
person's got it's it's a zero-sum game
where one person lives one person dies
the ai if it was deontological it could
not commit an immoral act against any
individual
yeah so it would recognize one person's
gonna die no matter what
i don't know which one so you have to
let both die in that case because
otherwise you'd be making a choice that
would lead to someone else's death
yeah i guess it would let the five
people die on the trolley yeah exactly
instead of the one the utilitarian would
let the one person die yeah i would let
the one person die and it's like
my husband he's catholic and he studies
philosophy and he often tells me that
i'm too
utilitarian because he is you know
deontological like that whereas i'm i'm
i like to think of it as pragmatism
what's the difference between
deontological and utilitarian
oh my gosh so this is where liam would
come in handy and it's funny because
he's explained this to me so many times
but i tend to tune out when he talks
it's all oversimplified for you spock is
utilitarian
and captain america is a deontologist
it's very simple spock said the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
captain america says we don't trade
lives right yes that is good
deontological is more like the idea that
an immoral act against an individual
like you you you are barred from the
ends do not justify the means
i guess right which the bad guys tend to
be utilitarian i guess in the instance
of spock he wasn't but that's
i'm not a fan of utilitarianism it's
where like
there's there's the problem with it is
that you start it's it's very much like
the equity argument you start trying to
decide
what about someone is worth more than
something else well i mean
not to bring up the avengers but that's
why thanos
was in favor of the infinity stones just
randomly selecting half the people
because he
believed the world was over or the
universe was overpopulated what an idiot
he was really dumb yeah the book made
him better he he was trying to please a
woman did you read the comments
well he was trying to please mistress
death yeah he wanted it
i like the that's the movie thing is
more appointments right that's the movie
is updated and it was originally
uh yeah he's utilitarian yeah he says
kill half of the universe just to
protect the other half but
and then what a few generations you're
back to where you started it's a
terrible idea
and someone i saw someone else uh
there's a meme where they're like why
didn't he just double the amount of
resources by snapping his fingers oh
yeah
because he's a bad guy because he was
trying to i
because he wanted a woman mr stefan so
here's here
here's my issue with the needs of the
money outweigh the needs of the few
you know the equity thing right they say
oh this person is more deserving than
that person for this reason you
mentioned it with a sandwich yes
the child's view the the child who has
no experience no wisdom
sees a hungry person and a well-fed
person and says give the sandwich to the
hungry person
and what the wise person says is well
hold on
why are you why is this person starving
and why is this person well fed
who made the sandwich there's a lot more
questions than just
i'm gonna give it to you so when it
comes to utilitarianism
here's here's here's the version of the
trolley problem i have
first you you know the trolley pro
trolley problem right there's a trolley
going on track and you have the switch
and you have to decide if it's going to
go down
and kill one person or go to this track
and kill five or something like that
there's a trolley heading down a track
with five people on it
it will hit and kill all five people you
can pull a lever to switch the track
with only one person on it
the act of switching the lever condemns
the one person who is safe
to begin with would you kill that one
person by your choice
who was safe to save five people so the
darker side of me says
who is that person but and who are the
other five
but i mean just philosophically speaking
i would okay now here's now here's the
bigger question
there's a bunch of iterations of the
trolley problem let's try it that's
right
ian what would you do would you let the
trolley kill the five people or would
you choose to kill the person no
no if i had a split second decision i
would kill one instead of five i would
say
so that means that one person who would
have normally lived you are choosing to
to
kill them to save those five yeah yes
okay now let's say
the one person has the cure for cancer
exactly
and and you know it and you know it oh
and he killed that five
you let the five die yeah see that's
where things become problematic with
utilitarianism
you as now let's play another game the
five people
are critical race theorists and the one
person is jordan peterson oh
i love jordan so you're saying the five
have the cancer and the one has the cure
no no what i'm saying is there's five
prominent critical race theorists and
one prominent
you know auntie i feel like i can't
answer this without people calling me a
murderous extremist right because
of and the crazy thing this is what the
government does this is their job
okay okay okay who dies let's take it
out of american politics okay
it's uh uh there's five supporters of
vladimir putin
and no this doesn't this doesn't work uh
yeah wait hold on okay yeah five
supporters of vladimir putin
and one opposition activist who's
prominent
save the one you'd save the one so the
issue is
now you're making moral judgments over
whose life is based on your subjective
view of what is right and what is wrong
that's the problem with utilitarianism
and they'll do like
there's you know they'll say like i
don't like saying black and white people
but let's just for whatever reason
there's there's 10 black people that
and by by the numbers say that they make
less money
so but then there's five white people
and the numbers say they make more money
so where are we going to send the money
we're going to send it to these 10 black
people but you find out later these 10
black people have
make way more money than these five-way
people they're just going by the numbers
in the book and making these these
capital gains and not by you know hours
worked but i mean i understand the
criticism that
you through utilitarianism you're
necessarily like putting your
moral values onto the situation but i
guess like in business they say even
making no decision is making a decision
so i my response to that would be that
it's impossible from like an ontological
perspective to avoid that most people
i think most people say they wouldn't
pull the lever they would ignore it
they don't want anything to do with it
because you are choosing so right now
the five people on the on the track
they're in that circumstance having
nothing to do with you
if you intervene you make the choice to
kill someone
so most people say i wouldn't but it's
essentially whether the ends
justify the means like in in the
scenario
if you kill someone essentially you make
the choice to pull that lever
it does end with five people being alive
versus
five people being dead so you both said
you'd pull the lever to save the five
right yeah
what if it's five eighty year olds and
one baby
i pulled a lever or sorry like i killed
the 80 year olds so you don't pull the
lever yeah i don't in that circumstance
you let them die
yeah so that's the problem with
utilitarianism you
have a personal subjective moral view on
who should live or die
and it's something but again i don't
think that's a problem of utilitarianism
versus just
an aspect of any philosophical grounding
it's like it's based on um what do they
call it when like you get
you get the numbers of how many people
live in this demographics it's based on
like demographic
you know book numbers in a book like
they don't know who needs what but
they're giving it to people based on
what they read
i guess like my my view of
utilitarianism is that
you are accepting the fact that losses
or deaths will happen
and then you approach the problem in
order to minimize the losses and
maximize the gain so i approach it
almost like business
you guys have seen all the memes that
have popped up about the trolley yeah my
favorite one is it's one single track
with a ton of people
yeah i see that lately and it says you
can stop the trolley at any time but it
would cause a loss of corporate
like profits are getting run over oh my
gosh it's like that
it's funny because there's corporations
that function that way
like that monsters inc meme like i'd let
a thousand children die before i
let this company burn or go under
whatever
yeah man so these are the these are the
tough questions we're getting into now
with uh technology ai
with the great reset with climate change
with healthcare even
if you're especially canadian or coming
from the nhs system there are
calls that need to be made and like
there's limited resources to go around
yeah i love how these leftists tweet
that there are no there's no such thing
as scarcity
there was a story about some kid in like
alabama or something there he needed
gene therapy that would cure his his
disease and it was like a million
dollars
and the state was like we can't pay that
sorry and then
people were complaining like you have to
pay you otherwise he dies like you have
no choice and they were like it's a
million dollars and they're like what's
the value of a life
and it's like yeah but we don't have it
like we can tax everybody i guess
what's the cost of a human life um
there's there's actual numbers you can
look up in terms of how the market
values human life yep
i think it's like 180 000 something is
what it's worth or what it costs yeah
based on the organs that could be sold
or something yeah
i see that's a tough that's a tough
number to figure out because what what
could they contribute to
society what are they going to take away
from that's why i mean like life
insurance proves that not everybody's
life is worth the same because not
everyone's going to get the same payout
if they die also i watch a lot of like
murder crimes
like don't get life insurance if you're
on rocky grounds with your spouse yeah
it's just gonna say if you're fighting
with your wife and she says she wants to
sign you a new life insurance policy
just yeah be
skeptical but i mean that the whole
issue of scarcity is when
like you were saying the left does not
understand and i think that's the reason
why we have so many of these economic
questions
regarding things like minimum wage
regarding health care is that they don't
want to accept that scarcity is
a real thing even regarding like the
housing situation yep
yeah i you know the the oil and gas
industry in the copper industry
has been holding us back from fusion
generation and like atomic printing and
like a
a land of less scarcity if not total you
know dissolution of scarcity
but and i think the critical theorists
see that and so they
they're acting as if they've already won
applies to everything yeah every
and it's not yet so so there's massive
scarcity right now
it's severely difficult to get materials
into the middle of the desert right now
maybe that'll change one day but you
know it's really crazy just like
because you mentioned the desert las
vegas is being terraformed
or reclaimed oh i heard that yeah
because they're bringing grass in
and then here's the craziest thing you
know what's changing the landscape of
las vegas more than anything else
human beings go into the bathroom huh
huh fertilizers they fly on planes
and they have water in their systems and
they land
and they deposit water they bring food
in with them
and they bring in more water than they
take out that's interesting it's really
crazy i was reading about it and they
said
food is the biggest contributor to the
the reclamation of las vegas
as well as grass they're shipping in
water they're planting grass the grass
helps retain moisture and they're
turning a desert into
like not desert whatever interesting
because i think they're they're trying
something along
china's border as well with the gobi
desert to prevent desertification
um they're planting like almost like a
green wall or something to try to
divide it they're doing that in the uh
the southern sahara
yeah they planted all these trees to
stop the desert from spreading
we got to start just doing those
projects it's like we want to go to mars
and stuff that's cool too but let's also
like reclaim all these deserts
yeah that sahara sand is ocean sand they
find seashells and stuff it seems like
it's from the great florida oil
the great because you have all the
microorganisms that kind of
oh interesting yeah that's why there's
oil we could put it back in the ocean
that's something i want to do the sahara
is
massive i know just dig it off build
drones that can just carry it into the
ocean like
thousands of miles what if like what if
they just
dug like a massive trench from the
middle of the sierra all the way to the
western coast and just like the water
flooded like a river
yeah probably that'd be cool new
beachfront
within the capabilities of human beings
right now i mean no it is but like not
within the willpower that would be a
great global human cause
is to what fix the sahara re-greenify
the sahara because it used to be a like
a
jungle like a like a forest with rivers
and rain it's
the desert's spreading so it's just
destroying organic matter and then
water gets ripped out and can't be held
what's the what's spreading it is it the
wind
yeah it like spreads the sand and stuff
like that makes it harder for plants to
grow
and so what's happening in vegas is
humans are rejecting it
humans are like forcing stuff to go
there
we're such a part of our ecosystem like
i was thinking of the animals that eat
the fruit that carried and then they
crap
out the seeds over there and then it
plants the tree and like that's we're
like that's us
isn't soil there's like dead stuff isn't
dirt like outside just dead stuff
i think yeah it's like so yeah like
we're just we just live on the on the
on the on the cemeteries of all the
billions of organisms that came before
us all that dirt
is yeah i gotta find out because yeah
look at all that before like what is
dirt i'm pretty sure it's like decayed
organic matter yeah just like rots there
and then the plants grow out of it
just the rotting corpses of the billions
of animals and bacteria and plants
and we're walking on top of it yeah wow
all right let's see it what is it all
right it's dirt dead organic matter dirt
is dead
it has none of the minerals nutrients or
living organisms found in soil
it is not an organized soil there is no
topsoil or hummus or worms yeah no look
up soil is dead and it's not okay i'll
look up
what is soil yeah like dirt's different
dirt's like the gritty stuff on the
sidewalk you know what i mean sand yeah
is soil dead so like when you walk out
into like the forest
all the ground is like that's like
decaying organic matter isn't it yeah
because like when the
when the trees fall or went out it just
stays there and then it
decays oh the well-decomposed organic
matter and soil the very dead
is called hum hummus humus humus
yeah i'm learning new things today i
like i like roasted garlic hummus
okay some use the term hummus to
describe all soil organic matter some
use to describe just the part you can't
see without a microscope
so maybe part of soil is is humus we are
standing
on a mass grave of life yeah and we
don't even realize we didn't care
i mean that's also what oil is that's
what's powering most things for us
yup yeah what a crazy reality
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you